preparing to do the thing isn't doing
the thing scheduling time to do the
thing isn't doing the thing making a
to-do list for the thing isn't doing the
thing telling people you're going to do
the thing isn't doing the thing
messaging friends who may or may not be
doing the thing isn't doing the thing
writing a banger tweet about how you're
going to do the thing isn't doing the
thing hating on yourself for not doing
the thing isn't doing the thing hating
on other people who have done the thing
isn't doing the thing the only thing
that is doing the thing is doing the
thing and I love this Insight that you
can dress it up however you want the
work just needs doing and you can fluff
it and you can change it and you can
talk about compounding But ultimately it
comes down to sitting at the desk and
answering the email opening the word
document recording the podcast one of
the things that I found is a really
great hack for me I would have no
success as a YouTuber that I've have had
being a podcaster because I work well
when I have someone else in front of me
so there are ways that doing the thing
can become more easy but ultimately the
work just needs doing